i think what get right represents to cs
go is
the overarching rich history and uh
and legacy of cs itself beyond just this
iteration of the game
it's one more kill looking forward he's
got him hunted down time is up oh my god
yeah what are you gonna be one second
left
get right may be the greatest counter
strike player
in history his game sense position tap
into bob there
able to catch dupree but steal the vice
get right having an amazing reader
situation
fantastic game sense and skill across
multiple incarnations of the game
are unmatched and they are walking in
right now he's looking for the shot here
you can see a couple of faces well
there's the one kill that's a good start
here but they're challenging them
they're fighting they're not scared
get right oh he gets all three kills
looking for monster crosstalk
shutting it down but despite his
incredible abilities
despite his unbelievable success get
right is also a player
that has experienced more losses and
more upsets
than almost any other pro he's seen it
all
from roster disputes to poor placements
to personal illness
and through that adversity he still
remained dedicated
to counter-strike he still loves the
game that gave him
everything more than anyone else this
is his story the get right certainly
steps up get right steps up
oh god damn right get all four
christopher get right allison was born
on may 29
1990 in sweden his brother robin
first showed him counter-strike when he
was just nine years old
and he was instantly hooked it wasn't
long before get right began to attend
lan parties and learning about the
competitive scene as he went
but you can't talk about get right
without talking about his biggest
inspiration
heaton the captain of sk gaming heaton
was a legend in swedish cs he wasn't
just the best player from the country
he was one of the best in the world
having won 11 major tournaments between
2001
and 2003. inspired by his hero's success
get right entered the competitive scene
and by 2007
he was playing in tournaments regularly
when his team
game passion won rendezvous 24 he was
quickly recruited by b
grip gaming once there he started making
waves with his solid play and great game
sense which helped take the team through
the eswc 2007 qualifier
it was at that qualifier where get right
would get to face off
against his idol ninjas in pajamas were
a little past their prime
and heaton was closing in on retirement
but none of it mattered
get right defeated heaton to qualify for
eswc
and he was ecstatic it was like just a
good feeling to win the game and
especially over someone that you've been
looking up to while bgrip didn't leave
much of a mark at the event
get right's performance signaled his
potential
get right moved on to sk gaming then
meet your makers
then back to sk gaming again while with
sk get right didn't get much play time
due to a lack of team chemistry he was
good
and he knew it but it was hard to fit in
with the roster's older players
after a brief stint with a number of
smaller teams get right was approached
by fnatic the team needed a shakeup and
saw the young wunderkind
as the guy they needed to put their team
back on the map
and at the iem season 3 world
championship get right helped fnatic go
undefeated in the group stage
and brush aside sk on route to the grand
finals
and in the grand finals get right showed
up
lord knows very very soon venetica
coming and get right opens up the
bracket the end lore would have had
four players to deal with but annika
still using that remember mr
a holding base finding the frag under
cuban now taz
and luke the last two alive it's all on
taz again
and he must be wondering what does he
have to do
to get this team to win a round fnatic
would bring down meet your maker 1613
to take home the 50 000 grand prize
fanatica homing in on victory as luke is
in the thick of things there khan
on the outside watching with baited
breath as the action unfolds on the
inside
forrest gets himself one more it's cuban
that goes down tas now will come back in
he's the last man standing for meteor
makers and the last
line of hope for the poles to take this
one back fanatico
going to win the intel extreme masters
the global finals they got off and
running and you saw what was going to be
the blueprint for dominance that year
the supportive element was khan and dsn
and then forrest
was revitalized early in the year and
then get right and gunks were incredibly
powerful and if they're your second and
third best players
that trio is gonna [ __ ] wreak havoc
and they destroyed teams
let's see there's lots of smoke down
here behind the hut get right we'll
take out crystal the three remaining
very good strong grenade coming in there
wally and carmel exchange two now forex
will pick up the hat-trick to put fnatic
into the grand final here in dubai they
beat sk
16-1 and 16-5 it was a very impressive
year for get right individually he
really started to
show mad firepower in terms of just
kills not
like insane name or anything he had like
good aim and
his spray was very very good at 1.6 you
could spray a lot more
and particularly towards the latter half
of the year he emerged just like a
potential star player
get right would spend two extremely
successful years with fnatic winning
eight premier tournaments
and while he was only a rookie when he
won his first tournament with them
he was something of a veteran by the
time he left but with that departure
came controversy
in late 2010 reports surfaced that get
right
forest and gucks wanted to bring sk
gaming's roban
and allen over to fnatic which would
have shoved karn and dsn
off a fanatic's roster when fnatic had
this meeting where the two sides made
their demands
the guys from forrest get right in and
that even said you know what if khan's
on dsn's side which he was
then [ __ ] it kick khan as well just get
into other players and we'll be the core
and fnatic decided fanatics owner was
very good friends with khan
to go with carter so khan can rebuild
the team and he let these star players
some of the best players in the world
leave the team
and so what happened was forrest and get
right went and joined sk the rivals of
fnatic
at the very end of the year get right
didn't miss a beat on sk
winning three premier events with them
in 2011 and as 1.6 grew older
get right's playstyle became more
refined he started developing a unique
lurking style
moving around the map silently and
catching his opponents off guard
combined with his incredible spray
control get right was an
absolute terror to play against
but as 2012 rolled around 1.6 was fading
away
and get right saw that a new game was
going to be the scene's future
cs go launched in august 2012
but get right was playing it in
tournaments while it was in beta
and as he kept playing cs go he was
approached by heaton
with an incredible offer heaton the man
who get right looked up to
and defeated all those years ago wanted
to bring back
nip with get right taking on a starring
role
on the new roster get right brought
forest with him to play alongside exist
freiburg and piflaren they won their
first tournament
steel series go and then they won again
[Applause]
and again and again
the new ninjas and pajamas were
unstoppable winning tournament after
tournament
from their first event in august of 2012
all the way to their 11th land in april
2013
nip didn't drop a single map
they had an 87 and oh land map streak
it was just very cool and surprising to
see that you actually can be so dominant
in a game and also that you were one of
the best players in the same time
they were imperious they were unbeatable
and this is justifiably so at the time
it was the craziest streak in history
it probably still is in many ways the
best streak the sickest streak you will
ever see
in the history of online competition nip
were all but untouchable in the early
days of cs go
and that was partially thanks to get
right's unbelievable understanding
of the game hopefully get right we'll do
something again with back seven
one two three france forget right
maybe even a fourth hit with a back
seven i don't believe my own eyes
will we have another shotgun ace here in
north dawn
very low in hp what in get remaining
we'll get my get this right
even more incredible is the fact that
get right was performing at the highest
level
all while suffering an ear infection
that required surgery
followed not long after by his diagnosis
with crohn's disease
a life-changing illness it's basically
like a sickness that
affects me every day every time that i
wake up
it's actually a very different day one
day can be good like i have no pain i'm
happy
my medicine is starting well the second
day can be like a living hell while
nip's star player had been facing
struggles outside of the game
the team began to suffer their own
struggles within it at star ladder star
series 5
nip's incredible land streak would come
to a shocking end
at the hands of virtus pro here we go
if you're flaring flashing over and oh
the smokes are so good right now if they
can get get in there and put the bomb
down it's all on through flower and he's
got it
and he's just going to be waiting to see
if anyone is there and if he decides no
one is so doubt the bomb is going to go
down all but adrian coming in from
behind get right with the kill
adrian with another one it's a double
kill for him great turn of events
adrian with a triple kill it's all an
exist if he loses this one round and
that's going to be it
16-14 they lose the first map versus pro
the first team in history to beat nip on
land despite losing their
air of invincibility nip would bounce
back
reclaiming their position on top of the
cs go world
off the back of an impressive win at
dreamhack 2014
nip headed into esl one cologne nip were
favorites at the tournament
and outside of a shaky performance on
kabul against epsilon in the group stage
they tore through the competition in the
bracket and in the grand finals against
fnatic
get right popped off showing up with
clutch
after clutch you hit an instant headshot
flusher coming in get right is looking
for it with the pistol and
they're trying to wrap around through
archway here and he's going to kick up
the kill on flusher
prim's now in library and this is back
into a three on three still 40 seconds
for an ip
to make our move krimz rotating back and
forth so much and get right comes up
with an insane hit they're cool but you
have two heavy hitters
rolling in ulfmeister only with 16 hp
but lethal just to save
and speaking of little hello get right
takes out jw
and now it is the two on one olefmeister
has to roll into the crossfire flashes
out ct
uses the molly to clear one half but we
have a man waiting on the side it is
before
who's going to keep him off the bomb and
the the molly actually backfires
old feister forced out into the open and
get right with the quad kill
last time the retake didn't work this
time they're feeling more solid care by
coming up from behind but he's also
alone
in a one-on-two throws out another
grenade here gets up another kill
is it happening again pronax is alone
that bomb is in the middle
of nowhere he's gonna have to sit down
and he already goes down get right
clutches and it happens again
oh my god get right down and here it
comes
two on 5 jw and flusha there is
nothing they can do any longer nip have
won
gamescom 2014 ladies and gentlemen
16 13. it finally happens
a year after nearly a year two second
place finishes dip
finally claim the title they are
the champions the win meant everything
to get right
who couldn't contain his emotions it
would be the only major trophy
he would ever hold
not long after their major win things
began to sour
for nip and after continued losses they
chose to forfeit tournaments and regroup
the team dropped the flareon and brought
on mykaleli in november
and while it worked in the short term
the honeymoon period wasn't long lived
the team failed to make it out of groups
at ios pantamara
and replaced michael laylee with del pan
in february
for king of majors by february 24th of
2015
nip made another change bringing in aloo
as the team's fifth man
and just like before the team's recovery
was all
too brief this is what i'm still talking
about the malfunctioning nip by may the
team's placements were becoming
inconsistent and despite a few scattered
victories at iem
oakland 2016 2017 and dreamhack valencia
2017
that inconsistency continues to this day
during this period nip's roster has been
a revolving door of talent around get
right and
forest the only remaining fragments of
what had once been
cs go's most dominant team
but despite the seemingly endless period
of adversity
get right remains dedicated to cs go
he's still an incredible player and has
been ranked in hltv's top 20 players
six times in his life taking the top
spot twice
and he's shown that he is still more
than capable of producing the incredible
ingenious plays that have made him a cs
legend has no idea get right to look at
the flank right yes he does he prevents
them from getting planted as well and
now it's a 1v1 fair with his get right
and get right
the clutch guard himself has been cling
that right might come from iv as well
but at too many angles to check and he
needs to land
a headshot with the sound and it's gonna
be get right what a god comes back in
forward of the smoke chest forward sees
the guns walking toward him and sprays
them down
whoa what is that frame
to try and roll through because it's not
that applicable but get right certainly
steps up
get right steps up he is gonna find
himself in the receiving end of a
battering here comes get right
he gets knife but peeks around and
destroys
twist and now this clutch is doable get
right
surely god said haven't just let this
round slip away
he's been dinked but the time is down
and get right
he's gonna clutch the round he can see
what it means to him
although get right's loyalty to nip may
have come at the expense of his trophy
cabinet
that quality has only added to his
legacy and his admiration within the cs
community
i've seen him uh with tears in his eyes
trying to
to make the right decision before he
plays for the fans he he loves the fans
and the fans love him as well you see
the emotion when he when he wins a
tournament so
you can ride along with him on his
journey like just the way
he's carried himself as well uh in the
highs and the lows he's somebody that
that people admire for his place for who
he is as a personality
get right is a counter-strike icon he's
one of the game's most
recognizable figures known for his
brilliant play
oh my god damn right that is old school
as well what a straight goofy attitude
i don't even know what question that was
but yes
an unbelievable dedication across
multiple iterations
of the game but that commitment to cs
his ability to keep playing despite
every way life beat him down
should be applauded get right isn't one
of the greatest cs players
ever just because of his incredible
skill and achievements
he loves the game more than anyone else
and that
is what makes him so fun to watch that
is what makes him
the most beloved cs player in the world
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you